to the late Queen Lady Susan Hussey was
as close as family
her lady in waiting she was chosen to
accompany her to Prince Philip's funeral
at this Buckingham Palace reception she
had been in conversation with ngozi
Fulani the chief executive of a leading
domestic abuse charity for black women
on social media she said lady Hussey
asked miss fellani several times where
she was from when she replied Hackney
lady Hussey persisted know what part of
Africa are you from I don't know they
didn't leave any records no but what
nationality are you I am born here and
am British she replied no but where do
you really come from where do your
people come from Lady Hussey asked my
people lady what is this this the
downfall of over 60 years of Royal
Service a figure at the very Heart Of
The Establishment married to the former
BBC chairman Marmaduke Hussey
she is godmother to Prince William here
wearing green she was officially the
Queen's lady in waiting for her
unofficial title was number one head
girl in the Royal household but her
resignation isn't good enough for Mandu
Reed who witnessed the conversation I
want to see them not minimize this not
try and paint this as an isolated
incident and and her as One Bad Apple I
want them to acknowledge how this is
institutional we're talking about
institutional racism here we're talking
about a system that allows and
normalizes that kind of interaction
Prince William condemned his Godmother's
comments writing from Boston I was
really disappointed to hear about the
guests experience at Buckingham Palace
last night racism has no place in our
society the comments were unacceptable
and it is right that the individual has
stepped aside with immediate effect
this episode Echoes the concerns raised
by the Duke and Duchess of Sussex of
racism within the firm these comments to
miss villani are yet another damaging
experience inside Palace walls Lady
Susan Hussey was deeply embedded within
the Royal Inner Circle but it's clear to
those inside that she simply could not
stay the palace acknowledged that her
comments were unacceptable and deeply
regrettable they've also said they've
reached out to miss villani who has
agreed to meet them
the chief executive says she was
insulted and traumatized by the incident
after being questioned about her British
nationality within the most British of
Institutions
at Buckingham Palace